vom gefühl heraus ziemlich schrecklich
wie ein wahr gewordener albtraum habe
ich es mir selber irgendwie versucht
weil ich zu viel anders gesehen habe
muss ich jetzt medikamente nehmen um
erregt zu werden um mit einem mädchen
überhaupt schlafen zu können also ich
hab dann überlegt wahrzunehmen
insgesamt vier blutgefäße am penis und
hier dieses angebot gefäße dass wir
gerade sehen ist richtig gut haben wir
eine top durchblutung möchte gerne dass
sie zu hause mal darauf achten wie sie
ihren penis eigentlich anfassen soll das
ist dass die sie sich das beigebracht
haben das größte problem ist dass männer
nicht mit anderen männern reden können
es gibt auch oder im freundeskreis so
gut wie keine möglichkeit mit freunden
darüber zu reden man wird sofort
stigmatisiert wenn man kann praktisch
gar nicht mehr klicken so richtig schön
fest wie eine kräftige reaktion ebenso
ein sorgen dafür dass über den penis
soll der punkt etwa eine halbe minute
[Applaus]
[Musik]